من كل التوفيقيه على الاتفاق الائتلافي مع
بيتس الاهلي اسمه توترتش زعيم الصهيونيه
الدينيه يكون بنيامين نتنياهو قد ازال
اكثر شركائه تعنتا واشدهم تطرفا من طريقه
نحو ارضي حكومته السادسه على الكنيست لنيل
الثقه قريبا سبوتريتش سيتولى حقيبه
الماليه
وسيستحوذ حزمه على الاداره المدنيه التي
تتحكم بكل مفاصل حياه الفلسطينيين حيث
يسعى الى الغاء دورها ودمج خدماتها في
اطار الوزارات الحكوميه وهو ما يشكل براي
كثيرين خطوه متقدمه نحوه تنفيذ الضم
الهادي للضفه الغربيه
الضم التدريجي
وايضا التطير العرقي في القدس وفرض
التقسيم الزماني والمكاني على المسجد
الاقصى هذا هو عنوان وجدول اعمال هذه
الحكومه اليمنيه المتطرفه في اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
بصفته وزيرا للامن القومي كما سيتولى
الاشراف على سرايا حرس الحدود ضد الضفه
الغربيه
تعيين على الربيع الاستيطان في مواقع
مؤثره سيمنحهم القدره على فرض اجنداتهم
المتطرفه اذ يسعى هؤلاء الى اطفاء الشرعيه
القانونيه على 65 بؤره استيطانيه عشوائيه
اقامها مستوطنون مسلحون دون اذن الحكومي
على اراضي الفلسطينيين الخاصه وهدم
منازلهم واجلاء عشرات التجمعات الفلسطينيه
في المناطق المصنفه
في طريقه لتشكيله حكومته السادسه ايضا
حكومه يمنيه دينيه اصليه خالص
يقولوا خصومه السياسيون انها لا تنظر
بتصيد خطير في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
فحسب بل ستقود حتما الى صدام مع المجتمع
الدولي ومع الاداره الامريكيه على وجه
الخصوص الجزيره بجنوب القدس المحتله